Okay.
It's time for hatred, mail, hatred, mail.
Of course when we hear from the haters of
the David Pakman show their voicemails a rather
their emails interpretively read by a professional
voiceover artist.
[inaudible]
no right of the people to keep and bear hates
shall not be in frame Patriot mail written
by patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom,
okay, this is just someone who I guess is,
is so angry with me that they want me to do
something that would be really bad that I
don't want to do and I'm not going to do.
Take a listen to this.
[inaudible]
very good.
You are a sick, deranged.
The snowflake try suicide.
America will be better off if you are dead
any watt you pussy Wakeling and take the tore.
Who birthed your loser?
Hell, when you go, Germany has embraced Eddie's
naughty past and you were just another Jew
hating Nazi.
It's only a matter of time before all you
deranged, deliberate socialist start exterminating
Jews all over Europe.
All you suck.
You're Muslim masters, you smell.
Yeah.
So listen, I don't, I don't like to joke about
suicide.
So my only commentary is if you are in a situation
where you were thinking of harming yourself
or uh, it is something, if you're in a situation
where you want to talk to someone, please
be aware that the national suicide prevention
lifeline is available 24 hours a day.
Okay.
The numbers, 800, two, seven, three 82 55,
uh, this is serious business.
Okay.
And I'm not even going to indulge the content
of this hatred mail other than to say, um,
I want everybody in the audience, uh, to know
that they can always talk to someone.
The national suicide prevention lifeline is
available.
800, two, seven, three eight two five, five,
uh, period.
Okay.
That's it.
That's what I want everybody to know.